oh look a presidential candidate in
picturesque Iowa everything is beautiful
at the Iowa State Fair even you 1100
pound pig it's a great backdrop for a
photo op or a grand entrance but then
the hot Sun comes out the greasy food
the crush of people and you wonder can
this really be an ideal place for voters
to meet presidential candidates can you
find Hillary Clinton in this shot as she
traveled through the agriculture
building I clocked Clinton at 0.12 miles
per hour that is literally slower than a
sloth and this crowd isn't always Iowa
nice we're gonna wind up in jail pretty
quick and he's to let again step back in
total Hillary Clinton walked for 62
minutes and covered one quarter of a
mile
temperatures got up into the 90s over
the weekend and many candidates took to
the soapbox stage for 20 minutes in
direct sunlight ben Carson opted for
short sleeves and drank a lot of water
whereas I did not see Jeb Bush drinking
much water dr. Carson how does the
temperature here compared to the soap
box actually the temperature right over
here is better this is a lot better
because it's a nice little cool breeze
block just a good place to hang out dry
off but back in the Sun Carson is asked
to pose for a few photos can I get your
victory that'll work up a sweat
so I have an idea instead of blocking
all over the fairgrounds candidates
could take the glider or better yet we
could put them in a cold room and let
people line up to see them it works for
the butter cow